Dark Souls the franchise that killed a
lot of its story and lore through
subtleties hints and small detail if you
want to really understand what's going
on in these games you're going to have
to look for it and you're going to have
to look pretty deep now there are
definitely some limitations to this kind
of storytelling but if it's done right
which it often is in this series it can
give us a rewarding complex narrative
that's deeper than just surface level
right now we're going to be looking at
just one example of this in the new DLC
the Ring City for Dark Souls 3 this one
instance implicitly tells us about three
developed and interconnected stores all
with just the ingenious placements of
one single item let's go see how Dark
Souls 3 total story the item we're going
to be looking at is being held by a
statue of Gwyn king of the gods
at first this piece of scenery just
tells a story of Gwyn and the pygmies
the smaller figure cowering next to Gwyn
is a pygmy member of a race of beings
that inherited a Power similar in
strength to Gwen's own when is
recognizing the strengths of the pygmies
by handing them a crown similar to his
own now while this is very lower
significant on its own the art from
software storytelling really shine when
we take a look at what Singh wins other
hand the brightly glowing white item
when we first see the bright glow we
assume it must be something pretty
amazing something that can rival the
crown of the pygmy that takes up Glen's
other hand so we find a secret door in
the elevator make our way to the statue
dropped down and the item is a 4 + 3 + 3
Rick the phrases stamina recovery speed
again the Lord of the gods while
recognizing and crowning one of the most
powerful beings in the universe is
holding a stamina recovery ring and this
ring of green bar regeneration is the
item I claim secretly tells a whole host
of story I know it first the realization
that the Grand item Gwyn is holding is a
quarantine ring can be a bit of a
letdown but after some further
investigation we can start to see the
intricacies behind the scene the
three interconnected avenues of story
that we're about to head down are as
follows rain city which is Gwen's gift
Fillion or which is Greene's daughter
and lastly Gwyn himself the first
connection here is the most obvious so
obvious that I missed hit my first time
through this ring at its most basic
level represents Gwyn handing the ring
city the area were playing in to the pig
knee the small and boy bander states for
the pig knees who took the Dark Soul the
Great Lord Gwyn gifted the ring city an
isolated place at World's End this city
at the end of the world was made as a
place for the pygmies a further note
that will come up more later is that it
does seem for a variety of reasons that
this wasn't the most benevolent kit and
it was more of a place to keep the
pygmies contained but I still haven't
revealed how any of this is related by
the corne theory ringing wins hand the
crux of this connection can be found
throughout the Rings city it's green the
Ring City is by far one of the greenest
and most alive areas in the whole game
parts of it are teeming with grass and
plant life and even some enemies aren't
fused with roots obviously this connects
to the growth focused recoveries of the
chlorin theory and still more when is
handing the pygmies a ring the name of
the city that he gave them is the ringed
City of course the ring represents the
city of a similar name so we've shown
our first connection and while it does
start to show the kind of implicit
storytelling that really amazes me it's
still a bit surface-level let's move on
and see how far down the rabbit hole
goes
the bulk of hidden metaphors and
symbolism in this case comes with
Fillion or some more context given by
the small and bored banner there are
also states that Gwyn gave the pygmies
his beloved youngest daughter promising
her that he would come for her when the
day came this daughter is filial and we
spend a good chunk of the DLC fighting
our way to her
Gillian or is very heavily associated
with young greenery and there is no
coincidence that she is in the green
ring city Goleta to her church is the
greenest most lush
area in the entire game including the
city grass and flowers abound making a
walk towards the church a beautiful
sight even with the dual wielding ring
tonight we do see these flowers
elsewhere in the game at the kiln of the
first plane however the ones near philia
are so much more filled with life
compared to the dead action ones of the
kiln we are further showing the greenery
surrounding Fillion or is not just
coincident the first reward for Fillion
ores covenant is the young grass do
which is a small transparent stone that
once great young grass crest this
reveals that the power of regrowth and
stamina recovery we find in the grass
crest shield and furthermore the oh so
important Corinth earrings seems to be
rooted in Fillion or this connection is
furthered by looking directly at Fillion
or and some of the unique enemies we
referenced earlier that reside
throughout the Ring City taking a closer
look at Fillion or we see what looks
almost like roots around her eye roots
obviously relating to growth and plant
life this intertwines with the overgrown
lothric nights and the overgrown
skeletons we find both enemies are
covered and filled with old dark roots
almost like a more realized version of
the roots in Fillion or zai these
enemies act almost exactly like their
non overgrown counterpart so the roots
covering them aren't hindering nothing
of the plant connections to Fillion or a
malignant one this continues through to
the grass crest shield and the chlorin
theory neither have anything to do with
facilitating violence against enemies or
anything harmful they only serve to help
the user recover their energy generally
from things like running and rolling
completely passive at the last binding
of cilia nor to vegetation growth life
even is the simplest and possibly the
strongest billion or is all that stands
between the green living ring city and
the barren action wastes waking her up
sends the world to its apocalyptic
wasteland
she is single-handedly sustaining all
the light in the rain city she is why
the Ring City is so green and filled
with life when the rest of the dark
old-world and barren and without her
everything crumbled well everything
except for us and Gail and one
stupefyingly persistent during night
wandering the way now we can see the
return to the clora through ring fully
this statue of Gwyn handing the pygmies
the strongest form of the Corinth
earring is symbolizing not only giving
the pig needs of the ring city but also
giving them the Leonor herself and the
fact that both of these are represented
by the same ring in the same statue also
furthers the connection between them it
is also important to note that Gwen's
handing the strong news clora theory
anything lesser wouldn't connect with
the power and importance of Gwen's
beloved daughter
Killian or finally we come all the way
full circle back to Guin himself he's
the one the statues of and he has
obvious deep connections to the Past to
layer what's important about him
specifically other than being the giver
of both the ring city and Fillion or
that Guin is known as the Lord of
sunlight the source of winds power his
lords hope is affiliated with light
energy lightning can son Lee the
connection between this stack and the
ring lies in etymology which is
something that has always been another
way that from salt has given subtle
story him the word chlorin thief shares
the same base as the word chlorophyll
which if you don't recall from biology
class is the name of the pigments that
make plant light green not to get too
technical but chlorophyll is a vital
part of photosynthesis the process by
which plants turn sunlight into the
energy they need to survive now I know
this sounds like a bit of a stretch but
roll with me on this one I assure you
the etymology is a big part from
software's storytelling when handing the
pygmy Accord the ring is reminding the
pygmy or at least implying that when in
the lord of sunlight is the source of
life and energy for the whole world
including the pygmy when is letting the
pygmies know that they are completely
dependent on him just as the plants are
vitally dependent in some
this case only can be made because of
winds essential role in killing the
ancient dragons and bringing about the
current age of five in which all live
and to some extent thrive when is often
linked metaphorically to the son after
all he is the Lord of sunlight so while
I know this seems a bit far out and
speculative I really think it holds up
what seemed like such a pointless item
for such a grand set-piece is actually a
powerful example of symbolism and
medical all told without telling by
making this so implicit from makes this
one room statute so much more than it
originally seems to be at first we see
Gwyn cramming a pygmy one power
recognizing another after our
investigation we see the original
picture but we also see the Ring City
Fillion or and win all being represented
in their own different yet connected
ways by this one little ring this statue
is able to bring three complicated
meaningful and arrogant stories out of a
simple ring by capitalizing on details
and subtleties this showcases how Dark
Souls has always done a fantastic job of
telling stories through little detail
Dark Souls 3 doesn't hold hands the
franchise is almost based on that
principle and so story and lore are no
exception this lets us dive into the
story however much we want to and if we
really want to let us learn so much
about the history and meaning of what's
around us and it does this in insightful
implicit ways that make us think and
really reward thorough investigation so
that's how Dark Soul 3 tells a story
thanks so much for watching and I have
to say that a lot of the lore and story
in this video was inspired by the
redditor gent who made a short comment
about this topic that I thought was so
insightful that it had to be made into a
video it was further fleshed out in a
lot of ways from a lot more discussion
hadn't read so huge thanks to all of you
over there it's honestly an amazing
community to learn about lower now if
only I could figure out what the heck
lore importance of the Ring night
wandering ashen waist honestly I had no
idea he just like such a random thing
I do want to say that I'm very aware
there are limitations and there are
maybe even inconsistencies and negative
to the style of storytelling from
software has and that a lot of it is
probably speculation by the player they
might not intend quite all of it don't
worry I'm not dissing other types of
storytelling I'm just trying to show the
nuanced positives that can be found in
this style of storytelling since most
games don't do it let me know if you
have any ideas about ending the lore I
talked about or the ring Knight or
anything else in comments below so I've
done the main lower points I've wanted
for this DLC and I'm not sure what net I
might be making the channel update video
as well since Dark Souls is kind of
closing out this is the last piece of
content and I've really only been doing
Dark Souls content for the past year I
need to figure out what I'm going to do
next with my channel I'm kind of
thinking destiny too here's how many
suggestions let me know in the comments
anyways thanks again a special thanks to
Ghent and the reddit Dark Souls
community I hope to see you in the next
bit
peace out